one of the people I love more than
anyone in this world is my mum she was
born in the 50s and like many heritage
she started work age 15 and expected to
retire and start receiving her state
pension at sixty that women retired at
60 and men at 65 was an understanding
woven into society for decades but in
1995 the pension age was equalized for
men and women to be 65 while there was
some communication it's fair to say it
was inadequate leaving many women
unaware this was compounded in 2011 when
the timetable for this change was
accelerated and the pension age rose
again this means that many women
approached their 60th birthday expecting
to retire only to find out they had to
carry on working for several more years
it threw many of their retirement plans
into disarray now I'm all for equality
but I truly believe that many women were
unfairly affected by these changes which
seemed to be ill-considered unfairly
implemented and poorly communicated so
it's time for the government to stop and
listen to their concerns oh and that's
from my mum by the time she retires
she's going to be almost 67 Michelle as
you know I am a passionate feminist but
I definitely am NOT when it comes to
this issue I do not want equality
inspiron it's concerned I completely
agree with you I think the way it's been
handled
has just been an absolute shambles and
actually the thing isn't about
equalizing the age of retirement is
about the preparation and the amount of
time that people were given to know
about these changes and prepare for them
so I'm with you and what I've found
really fascinating is I think the
government is going to have to do
something about this because this group
are totally organized aren't they and
mobilize and I don't think it's going
anywhere anytime soon so may I suggest
considering men died earlier
pause the menopause alone means men
because women live far longer than then
I think the perhaps women should retire
at an age older than women at this stage
bring in the Department for Work and
Pensions not to defend what's going on
but this because it's they have a right
to to reply to this and they have said
that as we are all living considerably
longer we need to adjust the pension age
to ensure the sustainability of the
state of the state pension now and for
future generations we have thoroughly
reviewed the options for equalizing the
state pension age listening to concerns
along the way as a result we have spent
an extra 1.1 billion pounds to ensure
that nobody will reach the state pension
more than 18 months beyond when they
would have done under the 1995 pensions
act timetable you know I mean I should
declare now I'm a waspey I'm sure you
all knew that anyway and I had no idea
about these pension changes that and I'm
I'm one of the lucky one
no sir I didn't I knew about it about
two years ago but but I'm one of the
lucky ones in that I'm still working
there are a lot of women in their early
60s who don't have the luxury of that
whom it was job came to an and a certain
age those women will never work again
though azuma will not get jobs and if
they don't get jobs again it'll be
filling supermarket shelves it'll be
doing something that's not terribly good
for they'll to get an apprenticeship
well it's just stupid and I know and I
think I calculated what I may have lost
by not getting the pension at sixty and
it's actually 40 grand yeah it's so far
I would I would have lost that now you
know I just think this government and
and previous ones fear forever
clobbering people in their sixties you
know collisions and I think I think it's
interesting watch in government know it
was it was it's been successive
governments as it's got is yes the time
I think it's easy to get lost in in the
sort of numbers in the detail and how
many women are losing what and actually
what I find interesting about this and
saddening is that it's a really a story
of the history of women in the workforce
and the fact that the reason women
retired at 60s a lot of them didn't have
jobs anyway turret are from and then at
60 they got a little bit of money from
the if they paid their Nick some
National Insurance stamp down and now
it's it
interesting because we're being
penalized look in yeah but we've got to
take care because when the government is
looking to make savings they say we're
going to go after women because women
don't take her pay attention to their
finances they won't notice this has
happened Biggio this is what's happening
with these women who go after women well
one of the really sounds like a lie yeah
there is there is we have the biggest
number of people at the moment and a lot
of my women who exist on nothing but the
state pension and the average state
pension a week is a hundred and
twenty-two quid I mean that is shocking
you know that's less than you would get
if you have some sort of bridging
arrangement so the women whose pension
as can be non-existent for those five
six years they thought they can get
something to make up for it I mean what
is the actual a case study there's a
lady here let's call her sue and she
really goes into detail in terms of her
circumstances and what she says is I was
born in 1954 I always work part-time
started paying into local government
pension scheme in 86 and planned and
expected my state pension at 60 in 2014
in 2011 I was made redundant due to
austerity in air to take out a
retirement on the grounds that I would
get my pension at 60 in 2014 in 2012 I
got a letter from DWP informing me my
state pension debt had been deferred to
2020 I never would have taken redundant
leave either
if I'd have known this the 1995 pension
Act and the acceleration of the 2011
pension Act has meant I've been affected
twice without you notice to make other
arrangements my retirement I will have
to sell my home I've been discriminated
against you too my date of birth and
gender now so strongly and I feel so
strongly about this woman's mental
health has been deeply affected because
of this and you say that this group is
mobilized but actually I worry for this
group because they're not mobilized
because when actually being they are no
actually what's happened you got many
fragmented groups campaigning for many
fragmented different outcomes you've got
people that want to have everything paid
back to the age of 60 and all the rest
of it you've got some people that just
want bridging and I worry for these
people because what they do need and
they need it incredibly quickly is
single voice one voice where they come
together they descend joke out there
it's a and they take legal action
against the government because I feel
sure there was nothing that the guy
Opperman who is the government minister
responsible has already said that it's a
done deal and they can't that's what I
was young generation on the horizon see
here from the chairman of the waspy
action group who is called pat Tarr
tellin the waspey campaign is fighting
on behalf of 1950s born women whose
state pension age was changed up to six
years with little or no notice some
women never even received a letter from
the DWP and arrived at their 60th
birthday to find they had to wait a
further six years before they received
their state pension it's a real lesson
isn't it when you get those brown
envelopes open them read yes read but
small print some of them never received
these so many of these ladies and this
is what a finish on there were not
informed you cannot be told for decades
that you will retire at 60 and then have
it changed with our noses